we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is
another voicemail again about the
possibility of a blue wave in the 2018
midterms take a listen hey David you
know why in the fall there will not be a
blue wave and for the presidential
election Trump will be reelected well I
just saw told us this morning that says
only twenty eight percent of young
people say they're definitely going to
vote in the election this fall this is
why the status poll is the way it is
though I hope you enjoy having Trump as
your president and the Republicans
controlling both houses of Congress
because this is a new normal I know I
thought that particular poll up to Bill
share in our interview yesterday and I
agree with you and I'm concerned and I
think that we may be headed towards
absolute and total disaster on November
6 2018 there is more show today it's
called the bonus show we'll talk about
Joe Lieberman urging New Yorkers to vote
against Alexandria Acacio Cortez will
talk about a major attack on the Battle
of vegan ideas ailments
don't lactate and thus you can't call
the almond or almond almond milk that's
I have trouble with that one
you can't call almond milk milk says the
FDA because it's not milk we will also
talk about a spike in liver disease
among young people which seems to be
related to alcohol you can get access to
the bonus show instantly by becoming a
member at WWJ in pakman.com or by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show